ayant commencé mais cannes aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur le mach most un jeu
de société dans lequel vont avoir une
gueule dégueulasse dans quelques
instants notre gueule va ressembler à la
gueule c'est joe staley ridicule voilà
absolument gros dès que tu le mets je
lance le samu il ya un paquet de cartes
devant toi t'en pioche
tu me les lits et si je devine la phrase
tu veux la carte de monthois sévérité
gagne un point fait glisser une aile
entre vos lèvres et vos dents d'un côté
de manière à ce qu'elle touche la terre
de notre joue deux grimpeurs de mortagne
à nice et moi il a mis au lit qu'on a
c'est plus mon ami bastien est ce que tu
aimerais mika a stick ou bien c'est
parti un chat fera et fut voilà dans la
course
quoi cherchant non hier encore il en est
un que nos avis et parler argent
non c'est fini tu as l'air au point je
suis prêt même si refait par mais que
veux dire par là franchement tu es beau
bon
la vieille valise la vieille valise de
ses excès de chéché est partie goudé est
parti vive et la dialyse de très
vieilles valises de tchatche et non la
jirga lise de paix fait partie ou des
deux 2 pp [ __ ] y'a même il ya peine
bord d'un bus voitures encore un
hippocampe j'avais réussi à trouver un
peu bon ok t'es pas un top voix
moi je rêve non la bohème chauve souris
nom pourri pour un show bravoure fonds -
one x et y
y à peine féminine difficulté enfin les
chevaux et les fourmis anicien opticiens
l'établissement ennuis siens aux nuits
sion mission toxines high tech 3 en
mission en russie on parle ici en
exploration ambitions après aussi la
commission gérard lui qui parle que en
mission impossible tom cruise bord de
mer ok à toi prononcé partie 7,7 à la
banane et est vraiment une bombe
cette banane est vraiment une bombe
mardi à monaco où je vis de ça qui est
magique à tous les petites vieilles la
vieille de 20 la veille la veille de la
fête de la fête des rfid maire a
bouleversé m'a bouleversé 1001 ils
filent ville et il fléchit recoler non
mais bon t'as vu qu'un mec le tout à
dieu tu galères à comprendre mission que
mon ami n'a pas rebondi dans
l'oreillette à l'été près troyes 2-1
cette fois je vais tout donner ce parti
qu'il arrive là il arriva fils paul si
chaque fils sert à la place les feux par
des faits faire baisser non du monde
rincez-les arrive à une toile à grossir
la symbolique à franchir la barre
symbolique aulas il arriva à cheval ils
arrivent
l'aria fille voilà peak oil
c'est parmi les plus aidés pead médias
je me suis tapé le mot petit poil je
vois capable de m'en vais
et moi car mon bébé ok bébé autres fuck
up phoque archi mon bébé phoque marche
vite c'est fini c'est fini
go wifi il sait faire oui cher il s'est
fait faire nul
il lui fait la paroisse de 1,7 à force
cet apport se chargeait de forger que
l'on veut dire que l'on ne vient
pâtissier dangereux oui et la fête
il a fait le fil des six défis y défier
des faits et des 1 décidément défier
bien tu prends ton fie aux rites et
c'est fini c'était quoi il a fait des
petits à givors manie bien besoin parce
que je suis fort on est sûr qu'elle me
marc fort mal qu'elle frimeur formelles
ont eu fort à faire au plus fantastique
trophy dia profit des biens viens viens
lipow
elles vivent au gré des râles l'animal
les bretonnes du centre à la place de
larry fink refi république recife le
bien immobilier de l'île ports et plus
revu je dirais plutôt attention dernier
le trust qui n'a tout simplement pas été
à souk à cette chasse est cartasi car
j'en ai c'est tout est possible c'est
marty top elle frise sur le bouffon quoi
free belle prise
monsieur le bouffon oui ok 1 cette
infamante lille ville il
enfin nantes ville qui me rend fou mais
juge la ville dit il
même quand j'ai pas le truc tu comprends
pas dans les caisses que je me doute qui
met de la bile tout sur un ton cheval
tout seul en forêt son poème howl a été
fait le vin était seulement jeudi le
jeûne amoureusement revue promis ouais
ils forment une forme ses dauphines
mais cette histoire le fim indochine un
muffin engins en vain oui c'est vouloir
s'en vouloir se joue là ce boudoir ce
boudoir à résoudre à vouloir c'est la
sopal ne pouvoir se jauger la
londe-les-maures var de bulma je crois
que la grosse vote toujours pas les
couilles frères leur ultime c'est parti
là le yacht au risotto
oui au tos eux au biotope tant
qu'intégrateur d'ajouter une touche into
you do we du viewty biotique n'attendez
pas des preuves et youssef du mieux team
super bon voila j'ai gagné qu'une carte
mais caches tu gagnes tu d'une carte
qu'une championnat tu veux as tu vu le
fond le cheval le fond le faut des
faubourgs de tambours faubourg des
chevaux des fours des formes et vos
efforts
white se faufiler c'est faut-il voir
dans les crânes dans les phrases je vise
je vise à les deux virgules
avec des virgules ouais ouais ça du
corps sociaux famille t'afficher non
c'est pour ça que tu m'as envoyé
non non on était arrivé au bout tu me
l'a pas dit on peut se qualifier c'est
la fin du tournoi gagné q vous savez
vous étiez avec moi c'est une triste je
les avais mis kia je te tiens bravo je
t'offre bassett peru que j'ai vu que tu
as pris goût à la 8e place
non non super non non bon eh bah voilà
les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur
le match mais je trouve que tu es
particulièrement forts à ce jeu et je
trouve que tu partes
qui a maintenu finalement comme certains
cas tout le monde s'était mis à l'eau